[Music]
all of us
in this room has had to pursue
a creative field because our heart
desired it right
and not all of us had parents that
endorsed that
well today we are gonna examine the
favorite
mid [ __ ] okay so am i the [ __ ] for
telling
my daughter that her art is not a job so
this is from the perspective
of a parent my daughter has been doing
digital art commissions online for the
past five years
now don't get me wrong i am glad that
she is able to be completely independent
with this and support both herself
and her boyfriend while he attends
college sounds like a job to me
oh [ __ ] but my problem she's successful
problem here is that i feel like she is
wasting all her life
all of her friends went off to actual
colleges and already graduated with
degrees that will help
get them somewhere wait there we go debt
i don't even know where my degree
is mom my dog literally under counter
did i ever pick mine up
or diploma what is a certificate plaque
i know i just saw it congrats on bart
paying a lot of money for this school
my daughter she took five classes in
community college
and said school's not for her and wanted
to focus on her art instead
i know this sounds shitty but i want to
have things
i can be proud of her for i want to tell
my colleagues and friends how i'm so
proud of my dollar
daughter graduated college i've tried
speaking to her and telling
her you know life moves on and maybe she
likes drawing
but she's almost 23 and it's like time
she starts thinking about her future
she's stuck in the past while her peers
are years ahead of her
already graduated and with some jobs
already she needs to
do she needs to do get up and get a real
job at some point
i'm only thinking about her future
because of this art thing she has no
college degree and
zero job experience in the last five
years she basically [ __ ] herself
but i still believe she could make it
work she just got angry with me she told
me to stop
trying to tell her what to do with her
life and she happily
come comfortable now i'm not trying to
dictate anything
but i'm trying to stress that she thinks
about her future for once
she refused to listen to anything i say
what is she going to um
what is she not going to have a real job
or any experiences to back her up for
another five years
i won't be supporting her then but i'm
willing to now and apparently she
doesn't want that
am i the [ __ ] yes when was he
supporting her now
stupid she's willing to support her now
my daughter
if she went back to school my daughter's
independent and i need to control her
life still
because i gotta look good in front of my
friends so she so she's her own boss and
he works for someone
else so he seems like she's beating her
i don't know if it's a mom or a dad
but it sounds like a mom nagging oh i
thought it was the dad i'm just kidding
i don't know
i really don't know where you picture
mom yeah
you picked your dad i picked your dad i
pictured a dad but i called him her
because he likes that
that's that's his pronoun that's true
wait so that identifies as her correct
she's independent but she's supporting
other people too what was it her
boyfriend
or her boyfriend yeah sounds pretty
[ __ ] helping him go to college
yeah what the hell and she's been doing
it for five years i know i love how
she's saying how she has no work
experience but
legit has the most experience out of all
her friends well no she's drawing
[ __ ]
stick figures all day you know she's
having fun she's [ __ ] around trying
[ __ ] doodles all day geo don't you
hear it what's a job then
like you have to be like an engineer or
something if you're stapling paper
that's a real job she didn't even want
this person doesn't even want their kid
to
have a career they want them to have a
job hey finally even what's a real job
okay not this [ __ ] nah sure no no no no
not that
oh like filing like that there's some
[ __ ]
dumbass people in the world huh you're
fanning out your nails no you're filing
filing like a filing cabinet oh
no that's like that's like you're
swimming no it's fingers bro
yeah oh and you have to lick it first
it does pose the question though some
people think there are real jobs and
fake
jobs well everyone likes to do the meme
of like
okay lesbian dance theory is not a real
job right that's the meme but
there are a bunch of jobs like that you
can get from getting a college degree
obviously yeah like
like that pay but the the current meme
is that
all of it's a waste and [ __ ] so all
college degrees are a waste oh that's
the meme right that's what people think
we're saying
right i know but we're not but this
person is taking it upon themselves to
control her
entire life that's some crazy she's
smarter because usually people don't do
that
on another day but probably during
quarantine she still has work
and her parent doesn't and usually
people that post on reddit
and they think like this they're not on
reddit they're like asian moms that
can't even go online
well how do they get on reddit then so
yeah to know to go to reddit no
this person that's what i'm saying like
the person with that thought process
won't go on reddit because i think when
you have access to the internet you stop
thinking so rigidly right
but this person somehow she's
infiltrated
sometimes when we're reading am i the
[ __ ] i'm like there's no way this
person
ever thought of themselves as an [ __ ]
enough to even go to am i the [ __ ]
they're looking for yeah people to say
you're right
you're looking for validation yeah yeah
exactly oh true
i think that's what it is when people go
on am i the [ __ ]
they probably have this feeling of guilt
but they want to know that they're not
guilty or they think they're that
[ __ ] right that they want to go see
all these other people agree with me so
you're
[ __ ] wrong oh she wanted to send the
link to her in your [ __ ] face
daughter look at all these people saying
you're wrong whenever we do this we
gotta put the link to the video in those
actual
ones you should it's like the guy who
goes on judge judy and he takes his
friend on there and then he loses
he's like taking your ass to court and
then they're like you lose and he's like
what [ __ ] are you talking about
this camp judy i love it i love it like
the ones that are so stupid i saw this
one like judge jody one where
this guy took this like his like ex-wife
for like literally selling her a car and
she was like
oh i didn't buy the car i didn't sign
any contracts and then he's like and she
was
signing in her favor right and he goes
oh well i have my like
piece of evidence and it's literally him
recording himself
and her signing the contract whole
wrecked
right like completely i love it so if i
could be a little logical right about
the fear
i think there is a fear from a parent
about freelancing
versus just being a part of a big
company
maybe stability well and it's also not
understanding the industry and how it
works
because if the mom knew like okay she's
building a portfolio
and if it's really good which it seems
like it might be and she's under high
demand
yeah it's like it's okay so she loses
this client but now she could start
like she could be doing so well she's
already supporting a person she might
already be able to start expanding her
business and how she has her own
i don't know it's just i just don't
think that they understand the scope of
it well to back the mom up or the dad up
a little bit maybe
they're thinking from perspective of
like well i the parent i'm still working
my job
i'm still in a position where i can help
out my kid
if they need help you know and if they
were to continue on this art path
then maybe in the future they might not
be doing so well who knows the longevity
of their
that career or whatever they're just you
know thinking like i'm not in control of
their
their doings so because that they're
still
you know in their careers they think
they can support them what during this
time
you know but then come 20 years when
they're retiring and they're retired
they're not even in a position now to
like help and
then the kids you know you know whatever
they they're going crazy with their
imagination
they see a future [ __ ] up they go hey
[ __ ]
when i retire you're not getting a piece
of this [ __ ]
i already see it you're gonna go bro
you're gonna come home running a [ __ ]
mommy and daddy
and then it's like damn it now i gotta
[ __ ] start you all over again
why can't you just work at the tyson
meat factory what the [ __ ]
the dark secret is that they want it
they want what they want them to run
home to mama oh
maybe you think so i do think so true it
gives them significance
it's hard to let go your children they
miss the control that they had over them
when they were in their house and so
they're still trying to do it here
and they want them to fail so they're
proven right that's true well but then
how do you explain
um the mom or that i don't know i keep
saying though uh the parent
being like you know it's kind of like
embarrassing when i have to explain to
my
peers what my daughter's doing that's
like for every like
uh so she sounds like it's probably not
like a white person but it's like sounds
like
like an ethnic family where that's how
it is you know it's more about like
different
places maybe it is my ex's parents were
like that they couldn't stand
that that my ex wasn't going for a
college degree or whatever and like they
couldn't brag about it to their friends
it's all about that
i don't know if it's a non-white thing
because i think like in some
social circles where they're competitive
and constantly like materialistic or
whatever
i think they all have friends like that
when they're doing sunday brunch they're
like
my son went to this and spring yeah i
would decide
where all the moms can gather that just
happens that's literally yeah
where do you think the college
admissions scandal came from it's a
bunch of parents who want to say their
kids are in stanford
the kids are at ro and rowing or sc
exactly
they got into sc
okay that's what i loved about my mom my
mom was always the first
one to talk the most [ __ ] about how
[ __ ] shitty we were
so she didn't like she was like i'm
gonna stay before they that's how she
competed though
she went ahead of all the other ladies
she's all like you guys brag
i'm a humble brag by telling them this
is a piece of [ __ ] right here yeah
that's what she would say she's like
[ __ ] she's shitty she talks she
[ __ ] she's not that bro that's the
ethnic game
parents do that [ __ ] they talk about
their kids to each other
and they do the humble brag though he
only got into harvard that's it can you
believe it only harvard
[ __ ] dude so apparently michael jordan
you know you guys are watching this
documentary about it yes
his daughter came out the last dance
well i don't know about that
but michael jordan basically anybody who
even slided him at hall a little bit he
takes it and he [ __ ] uses it to
become the greatest of all time right
so i want to do this thing now where we
all
collectively as a society agree to start
[ __ ] on michael jordan's legacy
just to see what the [ __ ] he does next
lebron's better no no like
like oh it's not good enough he has a
shoe company he's worth two billion
dollars that's not that good he's kind
of [ __ ] like
oh those shoes suck yeah they kind of
blow like i don't know michael they're
not that good anymore
what if he directs that anger at us
because he sees that we're the only of
us that's like he covered all those
bases
that's how we get to a [ __ ] michael
jordan space station where he's got like
a galactic empire set up and he's like
guess what [ __ ] i invented
space travel
we did that thank you we hated you into
space
i think he's giving a speech he's like i
wanted you all to be here because [ __ ]
you guys
i made space travel happen or he's like
i just gonna murder these people no no
no no no no he wouldn't that sounds like
he's not darth vader no kills like if
you go like if we're
like you're michael jordan i'm on the
opposite team um and i go
and i my team wins like a good game
michael
and then he'll take that till next
season and he's gonna [ __ ] go in
on you like those little ass things or
like hey good game michael and then
or michael's a hey good game and then
and then it's like nah and then
he [ __ ] is like oh next season oh my
god you're so good
he's like and then his coat his trainer
is like okay michael i'll see you in
four months
a lot of people say a great way to uh
channel negative energy
is through productivity like that and
obsess over it but through effective
means because most people if they get
hate they'll direct it don't be they'll
play it at the level of the hater and
they they'll stoop down to their level
right back at them
yeah and they'll fight them but other
people they'll be like
oh really well guess what that's what
i'm trying to send your whole entire
family
to the hospital oh no that's not the
journal no no it's not the drone okay
never mind
i don't like that for me it's like if
you talk to you like oh you're never
good i'm like
no well i'ma still do it i was gonna do
it anyway but you telling me
[ __ ] you or whatever was gonna make me
it's gonna be like oh damn this guy's an
[ __ ] but don't you want to go
oh really no because that person was
like what you guys just did about the
whole space thing
see it was because of me i did that
because of my no no no but you don't
tell them though yeah you don't you
don't tell them we're not supposed to
tell michael
that we're [ __ ] i know but it's like
i've had so many family they're like
don't move to l.a don't do this don't do
that and then like i move and i'm
doing better and they're like see we
pushed you like but doesn't it feel good
though when you go
yeah right no i just like dude i saw
what you said oh you oh so you go back
down to their level
huh you stoop down to them no in my head
i'm just like that's not what you said
but by the way that's what they need to
do because it gives them validation for
the meaningless for themselves yeah yeah
true so they had an effect on michael
everyone by the way who's around michael
claimed some sort of success
like that they had some part in it like
success breeds like a million
fathers and and failure uh is an orphan
scottie pippen can claim that though he
did he's he's the biggest lifter
i would say so he passed it to michael
but but scottie pippen's current job
is still putting michael on his top
right like carrying him like this and
going like he's got a percentage in the
air jordan
you know he's trying to you know but
that's why we need to be like yo michael
air jordan it's not that interesting
anymore everyone flies everyone's been
in the sky now
like and then he's like [ __ ] you
interstellar jordan
[ __ ] you guys
so
foreign